fans are getting a first look at nicole
kidman on the set of being the ricardo's
and she looks just like lucille ball i'm
very happy very very happy
the actress is transforming into the
hollywood icon
for her role in the aaron sorkin
directed biographical film
and that that's nicole on set
sporting lucy's fiery orange hair
being the ricardo's will tell the story
of lucy and her husband
desi arnaz who starred in the popular
1951 sitcom i love lucy
every month every single month your bank
account is overdrawn
now what is the reason you don't give me
enough money
the two tied the knot in 1940 and split
in 1960. as for nicole she posted
this snap from the closed set last week
alongside the caption
quote currently in production very
exciting
back in january the actress shared her
excitement over playing lucy
alongside javier bardem who is playing
desi
telling variety quote i was like yeah i
would love to give it a go
with aaron's words and his direction and
javier that's kind of a wonderful
prospect too you know
but yikes off we go give it a go
try my best see if i can do it nicole's
excitement over the role comes
after desi and lucy's daughter lucy
arnez spoke out on facebook in january
in an attempt to calm down fans who were
worked up over the film's
casting i felt i should just at least
try to calm the waters here um there
seems to be a lot of discussion about
nicole kidman that should be deborah
missing fans had taken to social media
to suggest that other actresses should
portray lucy
it felt very much like like a sort of
nod to lucy and desi
and deborah messing who previously
played the i love lucy star
during an episode of will and grace even
campaigned for the part
with vitamin a vegement you can spoon
your way to health
all you do is take a tablespoon after
every meal
it's so tasty too
no one has to impersonate lucy ricardo
nor do the vitamin regimen routine
or the chocolate factory routine or any
of the silly things
it's the story of lucille ball my actual
mother
not lucy ricardo and her husband desi
arnette
my dad not ricky ricardo
there will be humor in the film but it
is a story
of the two of them and how they met uh
and what went right with finding the
show
what went wrong their relationship their
love affair
just trust us it's gonna be a nice
film and p.s the voting is over
i love all of you and after seeing this
snap of nicole on set
seems like things are off to a great
start
[Music]